the buildup of forces uh is really quite
significant and yesterday uh russia
began the military exercises in belarus
that are due to the last 10 days and
that's 30 000 troops on the move
they've also put fighter aircraft into
belarus and they closed off large
swathes of the black sea and closed off
the sea of azov
so they've really escalated dramatically
uh the capacity that russia has that is
ready to move and what they can bring to
bear to the conflict on top of that one
has to speculate that maybe there's
something in signals intelligence that
the u.s has heard we don't know that for
a fact it would be classified
but the the degree of certainty with
which the u.s is addressing this now
makes one suspect that they have heard
something and i would just add that that
still doesn't mean that we know for sure
uh putin can decide to intervene or
decide not to and i think we may still
have an opportunity to try to persuade
him not to
yeah what came across for me certainly
was that real sense of urgency
especially when he said to american
citizens repeating that plea you need to
get out within the next 24 or 48 hours
and quite frankly we won't rescue you if
you choose to stay and this evening our
foreign office here in the uk has said
uh to british citizens as well that they
should consider uh leaving um
what is in putin's interest in invading
uh
what do you think is is going through
his mind in terms of what he could
actually win by carrying out an invasion
well i think there are several different
ways to look at that
one of them is to be building a greater
russia he wants to be one of the few
russian leaders who accumulated the
lands and who built a greater russia so
taking territory uh from ukraine where
russian speakers live i think that is
itself part of an objective he's done it
already with crimea and the eastern part
of donbass but he may like to have more
uh he also remember has taken over the
security services in belarus and in
kazakhstan and taken pieces of georgia
and moldova so this fits a pattern in
addition to that he's trying to rewrite
the european security architecture
since the 1970s we've had the helsinki
accords which have said that we respect
every nation in europe sovereignty and
territorial integrity and its right to
make its own choices about its security
and its political orientation putin
wants to tear that up and go back to
yalta where stalin and
roosevelt and churchill sat together and
drew a line across europe and said the
eastern part here is russia's sphere of
influence the rest of it is a western
sphere that's what putin really wants is
a recognition that
ukraine georgia any former soviet
territory parts of central and eastern
europe those are his and uh he's not
going to get that so he's going to try
to then carve out some of that by force
if he uses force but there is an
argument isn't there that he's in a far
stronger position by threatening and
bullying and intimidating rather than
invading becoming the world's pariah and
also having to take lots of dead russian
soldiers back to their mothers in body
bags
indeed and i think that that's a very
important point both uh
if the russian public sees that he is
killing ukrainians russian soldiers are
there dying as well it's
incontrovertibly russia that is the
aggressor here that will not get a lot
of understanding in moscow no matter how
much
the kremlin controls the media there
people will know and people won't
understand so that's one dynamic and the
other is you're exactly right by
building up the threats and making
demands like this he's already made some
achievements here that he can walk away
with
he's gotten all the world focused on him
he's had the u.s offer bilateral
meetings and arms control nuclear arms
control
exercise and transparency and confidence
building measures uh he's had macron
probably signal to him that france would
not support ukrainian nato membership so
he's probably accumulating a lot of that
already without invading uh we'll we
don't know whether he actually will
invade he certainly can and the forces
are there and ready but uh
i think what we need to do is focus on
those costs if we can make it guaranteed
that russia would face unacceptable
military costs if it invades ukraine
again um that is the best chance for
getting him not to do it
yeah so uh uh we've just got a minute
left but what is your assessment then
given that news conference given the
intense diplomacy that's been going on
over the last 24 48 hours what's your
assessment of of what happens next it's
a tricky question i know
yeah i know what what i think happens
next is the the west is drawing down a
bit i wish that what we were doing was
ramping up our support for ukraine more
security assistance more creative ways
of helping them maybe even some presence
of nato advisors uh really show that
this would be costly for putin i don't
know if we'll do that but i think that's
the right next step
yeah um uh of course the the problem in
all of this is nobody can read uh
putin's mind
yeah no that's right and uh he's he's
put in place the forces now so he's the
one who um can take the initiative or
not
okay uh kurt volcker former united
states permanent representative to nato
also served as u.s special
representative for ukraine negotiations
in 2017 and 2019. we appreciate your
analysis thank you very much indeed for
joining us